yeah what else a big go down J station
quit YouTube after he killed his
girlfriend that's crazy but what do you
mean he's awfully know yeah he is
yeah he's permanently demonetised you
can see that no permanently what the
[ __ ] is he gonna do I was gonna buy
Gucci hats I mean he made a video being
like I need to I've never seen a let
like someone try empathy so hard what do
you mean this [ __ ] couldn't cry
with a onion stapled to his [ __ ]
forehead Oh was he saying he's like
really trying to be sorry
he's never been sorry in his life I
defeat sorry it's it's kind of [ __ ]
awesome it's kind of hilarious like
Logan Paul's apology video no no his was
worse than that this was like someone
this was like an audition tape this was
a self tape alright imma hi I'm Jay
Station reading for the role of a sorry
youtuber yeah okay
and action wait wait wait slate first
I'm Jay Station I'm 29 and I live in
Toronto height please 6:1 okay when you
look more like five nine but that's fine
you can say 6 1 ah okay all right yeah
so so yeah the scene is just you're
you're very apologetic you're very sorry
for something you've done something
serious you know pretending to kill your
girlfriend or whatever maybe so just you
can improvise feel free and action
seeking so you guys are like probably
wondering why I'm making this video and
you know I've just had to look at myself
and [ __ ] what's the line
snow wines is this just improvising for
sure um yeah I'm like sorry or whatever
for killing my girlfriend it wasn't
really uh he just lays all this [ __ ]
said about how like he needs to take a
look at himself okay and it's just like
you'd like our laughing because like you
know when he looks at himself he sees
nothing wrong but good looks in the
mirror
he's just getting oranges Myron
it's like it's like you could see the
narcissism take over like he looks in
the mirror and he's like everyone says
I'm a bad person how could you be bad
when you look this good you you are bad
you're bad you're bad [ __ ] gestation
you're a bad mother [ __ ]
then he's a station your badass [ __ ]
and he rotates the goofy hat backwards
I know you're really bad ah you're so
bad they're [ __ ] knock it off
before you make me [ __ ] well you might
make me do some J station let's look in
the mirror no root snap out of it you're
sorry B cuz you're bad be sorry so
[ __ ] bad time for my Gucci hat off
dude bro I've been playing a shitload of
[ __ ] diablo three on my switch just
cuz of the plane okay burning a hole in
my brain oh yeah that's what made me
think the hype house was like a Chinese
gaming house oh nice yeah just just
grind and put in work within hours a
couple yeah yeah it's a little bit
shameful a little bit shame did you play
like the whole first flight yeah
a trip back was was brutal did not on a
[ __ ] I always have this fear mmm that
I'm gonna wake up on a plane and I have
either pissed myself or I had a wet
dream mmm it's the it's the weirdest
thing
mm-hmm I always wake up anyway yeah yeah
always always check my pants always
check my [ __ ] pants yeah cuz I've had
dreams where I took a piss in the dream
and I woke up like terrified that I had
pissed me yeah I've done that a couple
times we had a dream where you pissed
yourself and then actually peed a little
bit not like piss the bed but like peed
a little bit no okay like you it was
like about it go yeah yeah word yeah but
then I woke up I just mean like when I
get like if I go to sleep high and I
wake I'll have a dream like me because I
do this [ __ ] like to live on the edge
bro this is my edgy I drink a shitload
of water before going to sleep okay
after I smoked or whatever cuz my throat
gets dry it's reminding me yeah get
hydrated well that's just that's just D
sugar eyes color goal a bit sure it's
not even a word so yeah I'll drink like
so much [ __ ] water go to sleep with a
full bladder and I'm sure like just
while I'm dreaming I have the sensation
of needing to pee so I haven't
subsequently have a dream about taking a
whiz then I'll wake up like uh I'll go
piss mmm but I'm always afraid that I
did it usually yeah yeah yeah which
would be horribly embarrassing mmm-hmm
imagine having a wet dream on an
airplane an airplane but like one where
you're like if you're if you're if
you're sleeping sitting up then maybe
like you know your body gets more into
it you kind of act it out a little bit
no you're no you grab their thighs yeah
the fun
oh you wake up oh oh the dude by the
windows smiling at you
smells nice how was it oh you can smell
that yeah I can't oh [ __ ]
how was your orgasm was the other guy
yeah how was your orgasm was it as good
for you as it was for me because I felt
it honey
Zak galvanic isn't that one movie that
like election character he does [ __ ]
on your character you don't talk about
he's got the two pugs
oh yeah that's so funny ah how'd it feel
for you was it as good for you as for me
it says it was for me you gotta ask the
guy next to you but he's asleep did you
sorry [ __ ] it I just and then you gotta
like yeah all over he's the chair in
front of him you're covering up your
your tummy pants okay I'll go the other
I'll go like but first so you pooped
yourself a little bit oh sorry sir you
guys always have dreams are on a plane
where I'm you know I'm farting but I
really am fighting I I've recently
stopped giving a [ __ ] about farting on a
plane yeah I just do it I don't care
yeah I used to like actually care
because when people did it I would give
this but like life is too [ __ ] short
to give a [ __ ] about just just just fart
you don't run to the toilet and fart in
the toilet no I just fart no one is
gonna know it's me besides Kelsey she
knows the scent you know and then she
was yeah so I'm just imagining walking
up a wobbly ass playing with your [ __ ] e
pants just yeah just try not to
bumping into all the chairs and you're
walking past everyone and everyone's
like it's a [ __ ] chlorine the [ __ ]
I was like come oh honey did you smell
that
it smells like [ __ ] someone came what do
you even do you go to the bathroom I
obviously just thing that you take off
your pants and you just go yeah yeah
yeah you breathe hot breath oh and then
you pass out from hyperventilating and
your head hits the door and they they
think it's an emergency so then they
open the door hey Jan they Jimmy it open
the flight attendants do and you're in
there passed out call me pants off now
you you hold it up to the small small
little AC vent in your chair in your
middle seat
oh yes air out the air he was like I'll
just be a minute it'd just be a minute
and the smell of [ __ ] is just radiating
off the top this is hidden the immediate
six people around your venerated smell
income is the worst opera what a
distinct smell I've never heard it
described as chlorine before but that's
pretty accurate
yes chlorine man yeah stank yeah that's
it clean yeah clean come flat ow [ __ ]
oh my god fully grown people on the
plane just knowing exactly what it's
like not wanting to say it yes that's
did you absolutely not Gary did you not
know not Martha I would never never
you